[Music]
it is very difficult to make a
tradition very good excellent and then
perfect of course
it takes a lot of time
you have to be very serious very attentive
[Music]
in any case be crispy bombay
well that is of course then
the falcon interior is therefore an aveo
the irregular age of the small and
large bubbles and then above all a
particular taste is an enemy that is
humid
it's magic when you have this little taste
of wheat a skeptic at the crispy
also every year it  there is a competition for
the best tradition in paris, it is a
very difficult competition because it is
the competition with the most notoriety
in the world of bakery and
of course the croissant pain au
chocolat competition, but the most important c  is the
baguette
because precisely the baguette is
what represents the French symbol I
won the competition for the best
tradition of paris 2018 so now
the president people eat the bread  what I
do every day for me it's a
pleasure and an honor
so I go there every morning
personally because for me it's
a source of pride
now doing it is
incredible my father was born in Tunisia
in  tunisia we love bread because
with each dish we have to eat
with bread and then butter in the
80s he came to paris he
learned to make bread from a very young age
since I grew up  so in the
bakery I could see that a pair
had trouble finding young apprentices at the start
who were motivated
because it's a tiring job you get up
early and finish late I grew up next to him
and then  little by little he transmitted his
passion to me and we were finally able to win this
competition
by winning this prize, especially I wanted
for my parents because my parents
have been in the
business for 30 years and the prize for me is c  is a
recognition towards them of what they
taught me of all that they
endured since you  there it's a
tiring job they made a lot of
sacrifices here I am very proud
[Music]